Film Courage: Would you rather give your past
self advice or ask your future self a question?
Logan Burdick, Screenwriter: That's a
deep one. Ask my future self a question?
I guess that I only get to do one,
those are both really positive things.
I’m going to go with ask my future self
a question just because I feel luckily
I have the a personality in which I'm always
trying to figure things out and come up with
new and novel approaches to any problem either
creatively or from a career perspective. I would
to imagine that only gets better with age. I would
hope that future me would have a lot of insight
now because I guess the other problem with
that scenario is do you listen to you anyway
right? Because that's I feel again at least
myself and a lot of people I think that you
are a lot more headstrong when you haven't had as
much experience and you haven't failed in whatever
crazy ways that you failed. You think everything
that you're going to do is the correct answer
and so I think that it's a little hard to shake
yourself out of that until you've actually had
that experience. You go Oh that really did
not work but yeah I imagine that young me
probably would have been a little hubristic
and would not necessarily take old me's advice.
Film Courage: What would be the question
that you would ask your future self?
Logan: The question I would ask my future self?
Film Courage: Yeah, Dear Logan, I have a question…
Logan: A thousand percent legitimately I would ask
what steps do I need to take now to ensure
that I'm holistically happiest in the future?
I think a thing that a lot of entertainment
people struggle with or again maybe not a lot
of it or maybe it's just me but I think that
at least for me personally it's the idea of
again of chasing something that makes you
feel fulfilled. It's very easy to be okay
I've never had a movie made. Okay I had a movie
made but it wasn't a big enough movie, how do I
get a bigger movie made? Okay but it didn't star
these [people]. It's very easy to get into that
mindset and I think that it's really important
even though it's hard to try to take a step back
and go okay but but life still keeps going on
you need to try to focus on what makes you happy
in this moment what makes you feel fulfilled
in this moment and not get too caught up
in in the in the chasing of goals I do
obviously goals are extremely important
you're never going to reach whatever you're
never going to reach the fulfillment that
you want if you're not setting goals for yourself
and you're not taking these steps to actually
achieve things but I think that it's very
easy to make that solely the focus and when
that's solely the focus there's a lot that
you're missing that's going on all around you
we were talking about originally this idea of
okay does it look exactly again what I thought
of when I was a child my life yes or no is one
question but is what it is still really great
if you're looking to poke holes in something
you can always poke holes I'm sure that the
the richest most successful people on planet
earth have all the same problems that like
everyone has and the same the same regrets and the
same lack of whatever they feel they're missing
it's important to try to not focus on that
so bring it back around I think that that's what
I would be most interested in what strategies
future me has come up with to again to effectively
live in the moment and not get caught up in all
the what-ifs I think it's great that you're
talking about chasing this these goals because
I think that's so easy to do whether it's an
indie film or if you on a higher budgeted film
because there's a lot of hoopla when a trailer
comes out and then you're reading comments and
hopefully they're positive and then if the film
screen somewhere okay but some of that stuff is so
short-lived and then it's on to the next project
for so many people either whether they're working
on it or whether they're going to see it and so
a lot of that is just this it's the evolution
of a movie it's a a circle and and some of
that what seems satisfying is so short-lived
so you're always chasing that where people
are tweeting about it wow this is so cool or
it could be a crowdfunding campaign or whatever
and then it dies out and then you've got to go on
to a new thing so I think it's really easy
to to fall prey to that I think that it's
I think that it's important it's probably more
important now than ever because I think that
in these social media validation world that
we all live in it it feels if you're not doing
something to get that that validation and
that dopamine hit that you that you're not
that you're not on the you're not on
the right path or you're not doing
what needs to be done and those things are just
entirely different regardless of whether or not
regardless of whether or not you have
something to showcase in a moment it doesn't
it shouldn't be about that and I think that again
that's a thing that also lends itself to feeling
oh well I should be chasing this and there's
reasons that that is important but it's not
holistically the most important thing usually the
most important things are things that you're not
able to talk about or showcase or draw attention
to right when you actually sit down to do the work
nobody's giving you attention for that
nobody's nobody's validating for you for
that you have to validate yourself so yeah I
do feel more so than I think it's always been
an issue to be aware of but I feel more so
than ever it's something to be cognizant
of to not get caught up too much in that
and lose the forest for the trees I guess.
Which one would you choose and why?